It has been a pleasure to watch these
recent Barack Obama rallies for Joe Biden
socially distance to drive in rallies
in various parts of the country.
And part of the entertainment is that Trump gets
so triggered by it. On one hand, it's good to have
a reminder of what it's like to have a president
who speaks in complete sentences can articulate
an idea with a beginning, middle and an end.
But Trump's triggering has been delightful.
Here's Barack Obama in Miami saying we can't just
say it's OK for a president to lie constantly.
We can't just say, oh, it's fine.
If a president like 50 times a day.
Barack Obama going on to say, even
Florida man, the ubiquitous Florida man,
wouldn't do this stuff. Why are we accepting
it from the president of the United States?
For the man wouldn't even do this stuff.
Why are we accepting it from the president
of the United States, Barack Obama, just laughing
off the wacky claim from Trump that he's been the
best president for black folks since Abe Lincoln.
And, you know, he he loves talking about black
unemployment, says he's the best president
for black folks since Abe Lincoln. Wow.
And then this one I just love referring to the 60
Minutes interview with Lesley Stall, Barack Obama
acute, that accurately points out the
acute problem with a president not even
being able to sit through a tough interview.
And let me say I'd run for President Obama. So
I just want you to know it's it's a good idea to
have an answer to this question. It's a good idea
if you're running for reelection to say, here's
what I want to accomplish. What did Trump say?
He got mad and walked out of the interview.
He thought the questions were too tough.
Two top.
Miami, listen,
if he can answer a tough question, like what would
you like to do in your second term, then it's our
job to make sure he doesn't get a second term.
And that's why over. We got to work hard. Joe
Biden and Kamala Harris, the next president
and vice president, the United States
just very well done there by Barack Obama.
One more clip for you.
And I understand the president's coming to Florida
then. You think he's hard at work coming up with a
plan to get us out of this mess? Well, I don't
know, because I know he's had a tough week.
Everybody has been very unfair.
To Donald Trump this week.
So, again, Trump hugely triggered
by this tweeting out of control,
starting to tweet as Barack Obama was doing
these events for Joe Biden. Nobody's showing
up for Obama's hate laced speeches. 47 people,
no energy, but still better than Joe retweeting
nonsense about Joe Biden and Barack Obama killing
the coal industry as if that's a bad thing.
It's not true, but as if it's a bad thing. And if
elected, he will come after oil and gas, which we
hope he absolutely will. And then also tweeting
just while the quote just signed an order to
support the workers of Delphi Corp. and make sure
we protect the pensions of all American workers.
Obama Biden failed American workers and failed the
workers of Delphi. I always put American workers
first. Trump is so jealous of Barack Obama. It's
so clear and for good reason. Barack Obama is able
to coherently express political ideas. He's
able to connect with people in a human way.
You don't have to like his drone policy. You
don't have to like his position on warrantless
surveillance or whatever else. But Trump has much
reason to be jealous of Barack Obama. And I love
as a strategy bringing Barack Obama heavily for
these last two to three weeks. You're not seeing
George W. Bush out there for Donald Trump. And in
fact, from what we've heard, it's quite plausible
that George W. Bush is not even voting for Donald
Trump. Barack Obama will be a big presence over
the next eight days. I think it's great. We'll
be covering some of the events live on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook, and I am sure that the
triggering will continue for the next eight days.